- [Mark] All right, Marla.
Marla, where'd you grow up,
where ya from?
- [Marla] I was born and
raised in Dallas, Texas.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents growing up?
- Yeah I had great childhood.
I was raised on a thoroughbred ranch
and I had no brothers and sisters,
so I had a really great childhood.
- [Mark] Wow, that sounds nice.
What age were you when
you finally left home?
- I was 18, two weeks
after my 18th birthday.
My best friend and I pretty
much threw some darts
at a map and decided to come to Hollywood.
- [Mark] (laughs) And how's that gone?
- It's gone pretty good.
It's been a spree of...
I've traveled across country
and my favorite is Hawaii.
And I didn't get involved with drugs 'til
I was like in my late 30s,
so I was kinda like a bloomer on that.
And I find myself now in Skid Row
strung out on just about everything
and desperate to get into rehab
and it's been quite a
challenge getting in one.
- [Mark] So what drugs
are you using, currently?
- Fentanyl, heroin, crack
cocaine, weed, and alcohol.
- [Mark] So you don't use crystal meth?
- No, I can't stand crystal meth! (laughs)
- [Mark] (laughs) All right, and do you
have children of your own?
- Yeah, I have two girls.
I was sober for 12 years in there.
I took a break and got married
and had to two children.
- [Mark] And there was, so you were using
before that happened,
and then you got clean?
- Right.
- [Mark] How'd you get clean
from some of these drugs?
- I went to Tarzana Treatment Center
and I stayed clean
almost 11 years.
(sirens blaring)
- [Mark] And what got you to relapse?
- I went through a nasty divorce
and just wanted to check out for a while.
I had no idea it was going to
lead me down to Skid Row though.
This is pretty traumatic down here.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's pretty horrible.
- Yeah, very horrible down here.
- [Mark] So you're living in a tent?
- Yeah, I live in a tent
on the sidewalk right now
and I've been doing everything
I can to get my housing
but it just goes really slow.
It's really scary down here
for me 'cause I'm by myself
and I'm white, for one, so like they don't
treat me very nice down here.
They don't treat any while people
very nice down here. (chuckles)
- [Mark] Yeah, you're a minority, for one.
What are you doing for money now?
- I work on the streets, I prostitute,
and I go in stores and steal things
and bring 'em back and get 50
cents on the dollar for them.
- [Mark] Have you had arrests
for any of this stuff?
- Yeah, I've gotten
arrested for prostitution.
Yeah, it's just been one
big nightmare this time.
It's not fun like it used to be.
- [Mark] It was fun at one point?
- Yeah, at one point it was a lot of fun
to run the streets and run
'em up but it's not anymore.
It's more like survival now.
Yeah, and guys that pick
you up now are pretty crazy.
Some of 'em can be really mean.
- [Mark] Have you had instances
where they were violent or?
- Oh sure, yeah.
I've have 'em pull guns
and knives out on me.
Yeah, I've had some pretty
rough things happen.
Yeah, I can't hardly sleep anymore
'cause I have issues with
sleeping and waking up
and having people in my tent
and doing horrible things to me,
so it's hard for me to sleep now.
- [Mark] Yeah, I've heard that a lot
where women will wake up
with a guy in their tent.
- Yeah, a total stranger.
Yeah, it's pretty scary.
They do it a lot around here.
- [Mark] How many years
have you been on Skid Row?
- [Marla] I've been down
here fore six years now.
- [Mark] Six years.
How do you think that's changed
you, the six years here?
- [Marla] Oh wow, definitely
made my skin a little tougher
I would have to say and
just everyday dealing with people is,
everything down here is switched
around, it's so backwards.
When I get on the train
and go to Long Beach
or Hollywood or something, I
have to like reprogram myself
(laughs) 'cause, you know,
the way we live down here
and the way people treat you
and the way you treat people
is totally different down here than,
you know, in the real world.
- Yeah, it's a
totally different--
- Yeah, everything's pretty
backwards down here.
- [Mark] Do you still have
contact with your kids
or your family?
- [Marla] My husband, my
ex-husband won't let me
see or talk to them
while I'm getting loaded,
and my mom is all I have left
and they're all pretty
disappointed with me right now,
so I'm really trying to get into rehab
'cause I just don't see myself
lasting down here too
much longer, I don't.
- [Mark] What do you need in order
to get rehab to work to be clean? I mean--
- [Marla] Oh, I need some
insurance, some medical insurance,
which I just got, and yeah
like an ID and a social.
Every time I get ID and a social
and stuff my purse gets stolen.
It's really rough down here
keeping like credentials
and a cellphone, things
that you really need.
Everyday life that you need,
it's really difficult to keep
a hold of those things down here, yeah.
- [Mark] Everything gets stolen
like almost daily, right?
- Yeah yeah, I've had a hundred phones.
I blink and they get stolen.
Yeah, so it's really hard to keep
hold of like family and friends,
keep in touch with them 'cause
I can't keep a cellphone
and yeah, it's just really hard.
- [Mark] And if you don't do this
the alternative is you end up living
the rest of your life down here?
- Yeah, a lot of my friends
have died down here.
I don't wanna leave in a pine box.
- [Mark] Doing some of
the drugs you're doing
are pretty dangerous.
- Yeah, really dangerous.
You just get to a point where
you don't care sometimes.
And because you're so
isolated from everybody
who cares about you, you start believing
that nobody cares anymore.
It's just, it's a bunch of
bullshit your head feeds you.
You start to believe it.
- [Mark] And getting clean
from heroin, I've heard--
- It's really hard.
- I've heard it's like,
dying is preferable.
- Yeah, I really wanna do it
but nowadays it rough, you know,
because of insurance and medical
and the other type of drugs I'm on
it's like a really high
risk to get me clean
off of those things without, you know,
me go into seizures or
dying or something so
it's really challenging tryin'
get in to a medical facility
'cause none of them wanna help you
'cause you're such a high risk.
- [Mark] All right Marla.
Well thank you so much for coming in
and telling me your story and good luck
with getting into rehab and getting clean
from all this stuff.
- Thank you.
I'm determined.
- [Mark] Good for you!
All right, thank you.
- [Marla] Thank you.
I'm so glad you told me to come in,
asked me if you could come in again.
This one I'll use.